[Música]
o baile começa a valer
agora menina
[Música]
aí galera que assistiu ao canal do bom
vocês já sabem está aqui para fazer o
quarto vídeo no mesmo mês 20 quilos cura
o vaticano e gostei porque dormir 18 foi
um ano a mãe e filha a irmã que ano foi
esse que ano foi inédito que passou
voando passou muito rápido - eu que não
sei se é que eu fico na dúvida quando
era criança e morava há cinco anos a
passar gente comemorava a virada de mês
é oferecer nossas crianças comemorado
março [ __ ] que quatro colegas hugo na
boca bate no meu sangue fala muito do
euro não se mexe na escola eu pensava
que podia jogar o caderno forma que eu
lembrava queria ter volta a estudar
porque um mês de férias era muito grande
pergunta do iel com oito anos de idade
entrar de férias passaram um mês de
festa quando eu voltar meu nome tá tudo
de barba fumando hoje em dia toda hora o
ano acaba todo todo dia cabo então não
sei se é o que estou ficando adulto mas
passa rápido demais não tem punição será
a cara sexta feira embora sair
sexta-feira pessoa fala não dá pra
comprar o abadá o que carnaval comprar o
abadá ti faltam embora no domingo então
foi um domingo não posso porque veio e
outra passou rápido e foi lá lazio que
ano foi dormir 18 anos já tinha sido o
último a km 16 foi quando chegou domingo
ao certo falou o que quanto sou eu e meu
amigo chegou 2018 disse quanto é o caso
você me espere só tem 18 a dormir 18 foi
a tomou porrada usando meu bem querer
nomes 8 a greve dos caminhoneiros ainda
assim a gasolina no metal como eu disse
aumentar ao canalha vou ser cancelada e
ascó parados ou nenhum funcionário era
proteger o povo correndo é balela bala
só que ninguém saber que gaza não fazia
tanta foto chegarmos um composto que
tinha gasolina no carro fala ré 30 ae a
mp tretas grama não tenham 30 reais
então no américa e os caminhoneiros que
ninguém presta atenção todo mês o
canalha os caminhoneiros são paulo eu
mesmo parei de assistir game of thrones
comecei a assistir siga bem caminhoneiro
e os vôos eram cancelados e as pessoas
cultas não era o povo não teve que pedir
meu roubar ao lado estava louco para
comer no caminho alongar meu carro e
talca onde que morreu mas em rolante
bonzinho a série parece que se nuno
assis não mudei pra um ano é teu
amiguinho gilliard não é mãe maria
manuela não é mais pra o nando tá ela
vai preciso e parei para se desfazer de
tudo infelizmente esse ano você vai
tentanto começo chris cão é uma vida é
uma honra que não sei o que deu em 2018
todo mundo que fala e parece [ __ ]
todo mundo que se parece ao see maria ló
marina ruy barbosa bruna marquezine a
favela era tanta gente na equipa grande
que o pessoal tava comentando a foto o
nome já diz augusto costa também quero e
primeiro leilão ofertando primeiro lula
e outros chegando lá eu provei que
aprender o lugar a quem vai ser essa
belina marina silva termina aí pois não
mas o sinttav na ii por levarem tudo mas
não sei que você já conhece o partido
novo não é com a da clown acionado o
povo que bolsonaro aí o pai afirmou
jonathan pouco da culpa ea mãe você já
conhece o partido novo e o [ __ ] mesmo
povo está muito doente e é bom que o
povo não é que tá começando a eleição
pato à casa do funcionário do pai 31 o
lado da filha mas ela mesma da [ __ ] ea
mãe tem gente parte novo funcionário
ganhou o pai eu vou cantar povo é quem
dá a ninguém conheceu parte do novo
irmão que não é esse mas carro não sei
porque pessoal tá com nervos à flor da
pele mas já vai passar aí a pessoa chega
pra mim eu já vi o pedido de trânsito
nada falei [ __ ] e mesmo agora sou
obrigado eu adoro transam que você é
obrigado que o pessoal possa editar e
falando disso entra no twitter o jogo
atrasado que quer ver três horas da água
só não fala de ontário transição da
tarde e noite sem fazer nada
o envolveu dora dançando deus a coisa
mais aleatório que eu já vi na minha
vida foi joão dória trânsito eu acho que
fazer mais aleatório que só se fosse um
rolinho o filmando meu deus q ano todo
não tem como ficar mais estanque e toma
o sangue tranquilamente meu arroz com
lingüiça foi ao twitter para mesmo time
caído na capital do felipe é bater nos
peito porque ela nem como a linguiça que
também sentem copa ninguém que aconteceu
neymar quebrou o dedo dele fez cirurgia
mandar trazer outro de 1 100 da unipar
foi mais dois no pé deitar consegue dele
no pé nem matem se têm mais respeito
talvez nem mapa de importar mais
dezembro o dawa jud brinde e terra
comigo o que aconteceu mas esse ano além
de ficar na itália foto apareça manuel i
é brincadeira cara um morro a provar
isso brincou depois também aparece
numericamente ou frios quando larissa
manoela me contava no meio da rua e
batia com as bonecas é essa notícia da
minha o enderson presenteia a fã com
paralisia cerebral mentira calúnia a
unha eu não presente ninguém com
paralisia cerebral é que nem tem como eu
presente a alguém com paralisia cerebral
como é que eu vou dar para acelerar uma
pessoa é impossível dar um presente de
si e também mesmo que eu pudesse dar a
quem é que receber um presente o papel
presente equilíbrio é o que é um pouco
de paralisia cerebral a bacana eu tô
brincando o nome da matéria só isso na
verdade o presente e ele com a moto para
ele poder ir pra universidade só que eu
tenho dinheiro pra fazer a moto e
roubaram o dinheiro mas eu já comprei
outro moto ele está muito feliz em uma
universidade agora dirigindo olha que
legal caiu e se arrastou por mais de
orgulho meu ano de 2018 casa graças a
deus eu consegui muita coisa e consegui
ajudar muita gente pode dar um braço
para uma moça que não tinha um braço eu
pude dar uma moto adaptada para um cara
com paralisia cerebral e para a escola
estudar olha que coisa incrível é
desenvolver um show para a netflix e o
dinheiro que eles compraram foi um
milhão de reais do ou para crianças com
câncer no piauí
ele está fazendo as coisas até mostrar
pra se mostrar é pra falar que fez vai
tomar no cu vai à merda eu digo nós
porque nós porque se você lê no
instagram quem me segue instável não viu
mas vou repetir aqui pra vocês eu sou
muito feliz porque vocês a minha vida e
nem ninguém se não tiver gente a
assistir àquele estádio roberto caso
ninguém se tiver a receber as rotas que
ele joga para isso manuela não é ninguém
se não tiver menina vai comprar a boneca
deve bater até as pessoas que não gostam
de mim você que espera o vídeo sair só
falar de ir lá e que você é importante
pra mim também só porque quem precisa da
noite ela falou o dia agentes e do frio
para alocá lo e ainda precisa de muito
calor que nem tão cara do cara é agora
poder sentir saudade do frio eu também
preciso ter pessoas que me odeiam
dá muito valor vocês que me amam por
isso eu digo agora que eu amo você e
outra coisa que acontecer esse ano a
minha vida conseguiu evitar dois
suicídios de pessoas ao meu redor e eu
fiquei assim feliz por um lado não é por
ter essas pessoas comigo dá auxílio
trabalho ou tudo que eu pudesse fazer
que eu pudesse ajudar essa pessoa e três
porque esse ano o índice de suicídio
aumentou muito recebi muitas mensagens
de pessoas que tinham algum parente que
poxa estava marcado desde o meu show
tinha comprado ingresso junto a pessoa
simplesmente tirou a sua vida eu quero
dizer a você que está assistindo se você
tem algum problema
converse com seus amigos procure um
profissional eu sei que é difícil
começar porque eu também já me sentir no
fundo do poço estou falando isso pode
confortar não eu passei momentos muito
ruins a minha vida graças a deus deus
voltou à minha esposa na minha vida e
esgotou muitos amigos na minha vida que
me tiraram de uma depressão muito ruim
eu vou te falar da gente tá aqui cara
botei na minha cabeça a gente existe a
gente podia não existe a gente podia não
está aqui mas a gente passa a gente tá
uma aproveitar como amava no brincar com
os meus fãs estão aqui para me fazer
feliz pra te fazer feliz também se você
quiser conversar com eles é um dos
maiores orgulhos que eu tenho de ter
construído na minha vida é uma fanpage
legal pra [ __ ] vocês são muito legais
destaque foi a noiva são um só tempo é
importante estou falando é importante é
tão bonita natureza tão bonito os
animais são tão bonitos neto tão bem
feito assim sai por acaso não pode ser
por acaso sabe então tipo vamos ver
vamos chamar estou falando isso porque
não queria mais receber essa notícia
sabe assim que eu perco fã assim porque
tem um número de pessoas que têm que
está aqui não é porque tem 32 porque tem
não sei quantos milhões no começo
falavam já começam a ficar a não quero
receber esse tipo de notícia eu quero
ver todo mundo feliz eu quero ver as
pessoas que gostam de mim feliz eu quero
ver as pessoas que não gostam de mim
feliz também sabem não quero que ninguém
tira sua vida é só um recadinho que
tinha que fazer pra você você é
importante um feliz natal e um feliz ano
novo e aguarda em 2019 muito vídeo
porque a placa de ruby
não é só pela fae que pode ter não é
papai papai quero placa de ruby também
eu estou indo rumo aos 50 milhões agora
estou focado já clique em gostei aí eu
quero que você comente
embaixo qual foi a coisa mais estranha
ea coisa mais engraçada que aconteceu no
seu 2018 pode ser muito obrigado você
desce